this video was made possible by
squarespace
build your beautiful website for 10 off
at squarespace.com
wendover imagine a train that took you
from washington dc
to dallas texas in nine hours or paris
france to athens greece in nine hours
or adelaide south australia to perth
western australia in nine hours
these train trips actually take 44 hours
44 hours and 41 hours respectively
so the idea of making any of these trips
by train in nine hours
seems almost absurd in china though
that's reality
in september 2018 the country opened up
a brand new high-speed rail route
with direct trains from hong kong to
beijing this
is about the same distance as dc to
dallas paris to athens or adelaide to
perth and yet these trains make the trip
in only 8 hours and 56 minutes what
makes this even more impressive is that
10 years ago in 2008 at the time of the
beijing olympics
china's high-speed rail network
consisted of this
we'll have to zoom in because the extent
of the network was one 19-mile long
maglev train from shanghai airport to
the outskirts of shanghai
and a traditional high-speed rail line
from beijing to the coastal city of
chenjin
today ten years later that network has
expanded
into this china has eight times as much
high-speed track as france
10 times as much as japan 20 times as
much as the uk
and 500 times as much as the us in fact
china has
as much high-speed rail track as the
rest of the world
combined it is staggering the amount of
progress they have made
in such a short amount of time
traditionally
high-speed rail exists in small
countries with rich populations by the
likes of germany
france and japan china is neither of
these things
the country is enormous about the same
size as the us
and is also not rich while no longer
poor
china is definitively a middle-income
country
it's about as rich as mexico thailand or
brazil
in fact despite being the country with
the most high-speed rail in the world
china is also the poorest country in the
world to have any high-speed rail
despite the country's vast size china's
huge population
makes it very dense especially in the
east half this means that china does
have large cities close enough together
where it makes sense to take the train
rather than the plane trips like
guangzhou to changsha a distance of 350
miles
take taken hour by plane or 2 hours and
20 minutes by train
when factoring in the time it takes to
check in go through security and board
it absolutely makes sense to go by train
when traveling between these two cities
even without considering that the high
speed train is cheaper than flying
high-speed rail even makes sense in
china on longer routes where it wouldn't
in other countries
beijing and shanghai for example are
about 650 miles apart
normally that would be too far for
high-speed rail to make sense
paris and barcelona for example are 500
miles apart
closer than beijing and shanghai but
only two high-speed trains a day
run between the two cities compared to
about 20 flights
between beijing and shanghai on the
other hand about 50 flights run per day
compared to 41 trains
considering the trains carry far more
people each up to 1200
trains are therefore the dominant means
of transport between these two cities
there are a few differences between
these two routes for one
while beijing shanghai by train takes 4
hours and 28 minutes
paris barcelona despite being a shorter
distance takes a longer 6 hours and 25
minutes
the other factor though is about the
competition europe has an efficient air
transport network
dominated by budget airlines that are
often far cheaper than trains
you can find tickets for flights between
paris and barcelona for as little as 12
while the cheapest beijing shanghai
flights go for 74.
air travel within china is also far from
efficient
china southern china eastern and air
china the three largest chinese airlines
arrive on time an average of 67 66
and 63 percent of the time respectively
a big reason for this
is that there's just not enough room in
the skies
a majority of china's airspace is
military controlled meaning that there
are just these narrow flight corridors
that account for 30
of airspace where civilian planes can
fly with tons of planes and not much
room to fly
planes are frequently delayed by air
traffic control to wait for the airspace
to clear up which leads to the abysmal
on-time readings of the country's
airlines
while the beijing shanghai flight takes
only two hours the potential of delays
along with all the other factors that
make air travel slower help make the
train the popular means of transport
on this longer route other train routes
in china though
make less sense for example in 2014
the new high-speed train line opened
between longshot and rimchi
these two cities are relatively small by
china standards
they both have a population of 3.5
million and between them
are only small towns they're also not
close
about 1 000 miles separate them this
project could therefore be compared to
building a high-speed train from denver
to seattle
they're modestly sized cities a long
ways apart with nothing big
in between some people would use it but
it wouldn't make any financial sense
in china lanzhou and irunci are not
small cities but there's really nothing
big
in between and at that distance there's
no sense not flying
the langshoe irunci high speed train
takes 11 hours compared to the 2.5 hour
flight
and the construction cost of that line
was 20 billion dollars meaning that
if every seat on every train was filled
tickets would still have to cost 400
each way just to make back the
construction cost in 30 years
in reality tickets cost about 80 and
trains are far from full
meaning that this rail line is just
insanely far
from profitable the ticket revenues from
these trains reportedly don't even cover
the cost of electricity for the line
let alone construction and other
operating costs so
why would the chinese government sink so
much money into something that has no
prospects of really ever making money
well politics irumshi is the capital of
the xinjiang province
while 92 percent of china's population
is han chinese
the xinjiang province is primarily uigor
one of the minority ethnic groups of
china
and there has been an ongoing fairly
strong separatist movement by the
uygours from china that has often turned
violent
the central government in beijing
however wants the xinjiang province to
be just as integrated as the rest of the
country
and has tried a variety of methods to
force this including moving han chinese
into the region
and the imprisonment of wigors in
so-called re-education camps
the high-speed train is just the most
recent tactic to bring xinjiang closer
to beijing and this
is no secret the central government is
fully upfront in saying that the line
was built to promote as they call it
ethnic unity this isn't the first time
that they've used this tactic of
railroad politics
tibet a region even better known that
xinjiang for its independence movement
was the last region in china not to have
a railway due to its small population
and intense terrain
the central government still wanted to
build one though to bring it closer to
the rest of the country and so
they did trains now run directly from
beijing to lhasa tibet in 47 hours on
the highest elevation rail line
in the world these trains reach an
elevation of 16
640 feet so high that passengers have to
use direct
oxygen supply even the train to hong
kong serves the central government's
goal of further integrating hong kong
which is an autonomous special
administrative region into mainland
china
while high-speed trains to hong kong
certainly do make a lot more sense than
trains to the shenzhen province many
hong kongers have not greeted the new
service kindly
as they view it as an encroachment on
the autonomy guaranteed to them by hong
kong basic law
the most controversial part has not been
the fact that there's a train but rather
that the station in hong kong includes
an area that is effectively now part of
mainland china since people pass through
border controls before boarding the
train in hong kong
just like any country what having a
high-speed efficient rail network in
china is doing is bringing the country
together and making it stronger
even if it's bringing together people
that want to stay apart
no matter their motives it's clear that
china is building their high-speed rail
network
more efficiently than any other country
to compare
this is the plan for california's
high-speed rail line from san francisco
to the los
angeles area it's currently in very
early phases of construction and is
expected to open by 2029
of course that means that the time it
will take for california's high-speed
rail network to go from this to this
is the same as the time it took china's
high-speed rail network to go from this
to this
but the main thing to look at is cost
this california network is expected to
cost 77 billion dollars and is 520 miles
long
meaning that it will cost 148 million
dollars per mile to build
china on the other hand is building
their network at a cost of only 30
million dollars per mile
of course labor costs are lower in china
and their network crosses more rural
areas where land acquisition costs are
lower but
what's more meaningful is that they've
turned building high-speed rail into
almost an assembly line process
where they can mass produce even the
most expensive elements like viaducts
and tunnels
in true chinese fashion with scale
they're making high speed
cheaper the big difference between china
and a lot of the western world
particularly countries like the us
canada australia new zealand and the uk
is that high-speed rail is at the top of
the government's priorities
unsurprisingly given their government
structure in many ways
china has placed social benefits at
least by the definition of the central
government
ahead of profitability when developing
their high-speed rail network
high-speed rail lines just aren't as
profitable as other means of transport
like planes
but they are undoubtedly better for
countries so you have to consider the
social benefit
when looking at their overall
profitability for the san francisco
la high speed rail route for example one
study found that the social benefit
derived from lower carbon emissions
higher worker productivity and reduced
casualties from fewer people on the road
would be equivalent to about 440 million
dollars per year
as it turns out this is almost the exact
amount that the state will have to
subsidize the line for it to break even
the china railway corporation a
state-owned enterprise is actually
slightly profitable
although it does have huge amounts of
debts and is helped by government
subsidies
the benefit to the chinese people though
is huge the high speed rail allows those
who can't afford to live
in the most expensive cities like
beijing shanghai and guangzhou
to easily commute from cheaper suburbs
by high-speed rail
thanks to the high-speed rail there are
now 75 million people who can commute to
shanghai in
under an hour it is growing what are
already some of the largest cities
and when it comes to cities size is
strength
these lines connecting the east's
largest cities are some of the most
profitable rail lines in the world
and they're making living and working in
china easier but the question
is when we look back decades from now
whether the high-speed trains to smaller
cities will have made sense
out of a desire to keep the lines going
straight between the big cities the
stops for smaller cities are often out
in the countryside
dozens of miles away from the city core
the high-speed station for hong yang for
example
a smaller city of only a million is
about a 45-minute drive east of the city
center
the hope is that new development will
spring up around the stations
but this network structure even if it
saves time on the train
wastes time before and after which
degrades the benefit of high-speed rail
in all china is really the first country
to have experimented with long-distance
high-speed rail through less dense areas
in its west in the east though
these trains are enlarging the country's
economic power it's just one of the many
factors speeding up china's catch-up
with the world's richest countries
even though china is building these
trains for less and innovating on the
construction of high-speed rail
the real reason why china is so good at
building railways
is because they have the one thing that
almost every other country lacks
the political will for high-speed trains
whenever i'm looking to launch something
new one of the first things i think
about is how to present it online
i think about domain names emails
websites and where i always go to do all
that
is squarespace as you probably know by
now squarespace is the all-in-one
solution to building a web presence for
whatever you do
being in the internet age it's
incredibly important to present yourself
well online
and squarespace's beautiful designer
templates customizable website builder
and 24 7 award-winning customer support
help you do all that
for a reasonable monthly cost it's a
much better solution than learning how
to code a website or paying someone
thousands to do it
it is also of course made easier by the
fact that you can get 10 off by going to
squarespace.comwendover and you'll be
supporting the show by using that link